الينا من كيف الكسندر كورينكو وهو نائب
رئيس البرلمان الاوكراني سيده الكسندر هل
هناك اي افاق للعوده الى اتفاق الحبوب
في الاوقات
الحاليه هذا يعتمد على المجتمع الدولي
الذي هل سيتمكن ان يقنع الطرف الروسي
بالاستمرار ام لا ان اوكرانيا بشكل تام لم
ترفض ابدا ان تستمر بالقيام بواجباتها حتى
توصل هذه الحبوب للسوق العالميه او
لافريقيا او لاسيا ان الحبوب
الاوكرانيه التي تطحن وتجهز الان في كل
دقيقه في كل اوكرانيا جاهزه لهذا لذلك هذه
المسائل يجب ان تعد مع الطرف الروسي حتى
تستمر
وليس الاستمرار الاتفاقيه فقط بل لتتوقف
روسيا عن استخدام الارهاب ان روسيا طوال
اسابيع تقصف الموانئ وتدمر البنيه التحتيه
لنقل الحبوب
وهذه وتقصف حدود قريبه من الناتو وهي
تستمر بهذه
الاستفزازات وتقوم بالضغط على المجتمع
الدولي بهذا
هل تعولون على الدور التركي لتوفيق بين
الاطراف وقد قال اردوغان هذا اليوم وقال
بان تركيا وروسيا متفقتان على الاستمرار
في ارسال القمح الى الدول الفقيره
طبع تركيا هي
شريك مهم جدا لنا وهي تدعمنا في
تجديد واعاده التوازن في البحر الاسود
ونحن نتمنى ان الاعمال التركيه سوف تكون
فعاله وانها سوف تستطيع بهذه الطريقه ان
تؤثر على روسيا الفيدراليه حتى تعود
لاتفاقيه الحبوب وان تتوقف عن الارهاب
بالحبوب ولكن يجب ان نفهم ان روسيا سوف
تستمر باعمالها
عن ذلك الضغط الاقتصادي الموجه اللي طرد
روسيا من السوق العالميه للحبوب وحتى
يهددوا الاقتصاد الاوكراني هم وجدوا انهم
لم يستطيعوا ان يسيطروا على اوكرانيا
طوالي العام والنصف لذلك يستخدموا هذه
الاساليب الارهابيه طيب اذا كان هناك
اتفاق الى اي مدى يمكن تامين ممرات مائيه
على البحر الاسود هنا نتحدث عن الدور
اوكرانيا ماذا بامكان اوكرانيا هل تستطيع
فعلا ان تقدم حمايه لهذه الممرات
وكريمه
اوكرانيا في الاوضاع الحاليه تؤمن
السفن
وممراتها
والموانئ في
دنيسكو وغيرها هي مؤمنه
وسوف نستطيع ان نحمل سفننا
بالحبوب لكن
بالنسبه
لقدرات
قوه الروسيه في البحر الاسود لقد تنازلت
وهبطت قدراتهم لدرجه كبيره وهم لكنهم
يستخدمون البحر الاسود لاطلاق الصواريخ
على
مدن الامنه ويستخدمون المياه في البحر
الاسود لاطلاق المسيرات ان اوكرانيا شريك
ذو ثقه في الساحه العالميه
ونحن ننتظر جهود من دول ثالثه هذه الدول
التي تطلب الحبوب الاوكرانيه وروسيا تحاول
استغلال هذه الظروف
الكسندر كورنينكو ونائب رئيس البرلمان
الاوكراني المتحدثا من كيف شكرا جزيلا لك